des partisans de denture envahissent le
capitole encouragés par le président
lui-même
quelques heures plus tôt nous
n'abandonnerons jamais nous ne
considérons pas la défaite dit il devant
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
venues lui demander de rester en poste
[Musique]
alois gonds
nous allons marcher sur pennsylvania
avenue où nous allons au capitole nous
allons reprendre notre pays pendant que
mike pence préside la séance du congrès
pour certifier les résultats de
l'élection des extrémistes s'avance sur
les marches du capitole et paas la
sécurité une partie de la horde une fois
à l'intérieur se retrouve devant un
policier complètement seul
[Applaudissements]
des échauffourées éclatent la folle
woeth entrer dans les chambres du
congrès une confrontation armée aux
portes de la chambre des représentants
où se tenait le vch président quelques
minutes plus tôt des élus se cachent
sous leur siège d'autres sont évacués
un représentant républicain une fois en
sécurité envoie sur twitter un message à
donald trump
oui gatti staps mister you guys are you
doing proches ou king krule vis oh alors
que d'autres décrivent la scène au
téléphone
si cela se produisait n'importe où
ailleurs dans le monde affirme cet autre
élu républicain nous dirions que c'est
un coup d'état une insurrection qui
atteint le parquet du sénat notre
démocratie subit un assaut sans
précédent déclare joe biden il appelle
lui aussi le président à y mettre un
terme
cet apport il répond finalement dans une
vidéo préenregistrée publié sur son
compte personnel
alors il a invité ses partisans à
rentrer chez eux mais répète que
l'élection était frauduleuse
le message a été carrément effacé par
tous et eu une première aux compacts
mois à 20 ans ils sont de retour pour
confirmer la victoire de joe biden mais
les images de la journée resteront
gravés dans la mémoire collective
américaine ici sébastien desrosiers
radio canada morrell